is lying to you in every video even in
this one because our videos distill very
complex subjects into flashy ten minute
pieces and unfortunately reality is well
complicated
the question of how we deal with that is
central to what we do on this channel
and something we think about a lot
[Music]
what we mean by lying is the concept of
lies to children
the idea that on the path to explaining
something complicated you start off with
a little lie a useful oversimplification
that makes it easier to grasp a concept
for example as a kid you learn that the
earth is a sphere orbiting the sun with
planet bodies but it's not actually a
sphere and the buddies are super
different in size and not close to each
other at all
by beginning at a place of
oversimplification you're building a
framework a foundation that you can then
build upon and add nuance and complexity
later on
step by step you're getting towards the
real gist of the complicated subject
science communication has to use lies to
children to some degree or it turns into
science education and getting a proper
education in all of the scientific
fields would take years of intense study
to become fluent in them as a species we
have a major interest in summarizing
science and its advancements and
educating as many people about it as
possible because we all benefit if more
people have a fact-based scientific
world view
we will discuss what science is and how
it works in different videos in more
detail but for now let's just say it's a
process to advance organize predict and
test our knowledge about the universe
if you understand the current state of
scientific knowledge then you can make
better decisions based on facts and
testable ideas rather than outdated
belief systems or our intuition that
evolved to protect our ancestors from
lions but is no longer suited for the
complexity of our modern world our
brains are comically ill prepared to
navigate the fast-moving world we happen
to live in today a world ironically
created by science
a few hundred years ago it was possible
to be knowledgeable at an expert level
in pretty much every field of study
in the information age this is a futile
endeavor since knowledge and data are
increasing exponentially
so to even have a chance of grasping the
world we live in we need summaries that
give us if not a true understanding of
all the details a solid overview
explaining science to many people is not
about enlightening the ignorant but
necessary for the progress of our
species at large
to make this possible we need to find
metaphors and stories that capture the
true nature of things as much as
possible while using a language that our
brains can deal with
a great example here is physics
quarks are often depicted as blue red
and green with different spins
but just saying spin and using colors
forces our brain to imagine colorful
spinning balls
which is great to visualize the
different types and the relationships
between quarks but also creates a very
wrong image of reality in our heads
molecules are nothing like the neat
diagrams that we're taught in school but
buzzing and vibrating entities held
together by something we call charge
that describes how certain things want
to be close or escape each other for
some unknown reason
we're describing phenomena that we are
pretty sure exist in some form or
another because the maths works out and
we can do real world experiments and
predict their results before we do them
in reality these are models tricks to
summarize what we know and make up a
coherent story and prepare the ground
for more in-depth explanations
don't confuse the description of a thing
for the thing itself
simplifications like these are not just
meant to dumb things down they're
actually useful for experts themselves
for example chemists who use wrong
electron shell models to work out
chemical bonds or scientists using
simplified models as the basis for
discussion with colleagues across
different scientific fields
but the simplification of science can
also be problematic for a bunch of
reasons
finding the true nature of reality is
super hard because our brains did not
evolve for this job and the universe
doesn't care if we understand it
science is a process to work towards
gaining knowledge and not an absolute
truth generator
the answers it provides are
multi-layered and nuanced and that
complexity can get lost when it
simplifies especially when it's done so
for headlines
an interesting cancer study turns into a
potential cure a healthy food becomes
the basis for a new diet
such simplifications give a misleading
definiteness to science which goes
against its process like nature
when cures don't materialize and diets
don't turn out to be magical we lose
confidence in science and start to think
of all science communication as
misleading
then there's the opposite effect
if a simplification is too engaging if
the story it tells is too good it can
distort the true complexity of a subject
and give you a full sense of security
and an illusion of deep knowledge
a gut feeling that you understand the
science better than you actually do
which can lead people to ignore actual
experts over their dangerous superficial
knowledge and gut feeling
and this can have negative consequences
for all of us because in the worst case
overconfidence in your own understanding
of science can lead to bad decisions
made with confidence
just think of the search of people that
confidently disavow vaccines or climate
change without truly understanding the
subject matter
so considering all of this and the fact
that we at kutzgazart reach millions of
people with our videos how do we handle
this
well it has been a journey especially
the research
when we started we just read articles
then moved on to books peer-reviewed
papers then to conversations with
experts we began to collect our sources
with every step we realized that we were
still not doing enough
nowadays we try to read as many primary
sources as possible talk to multiple
experts and document our simplifications
and give further reading in our sources
doc
but this doesn't make our process
flawless
what do you do if experts disagree with
each other
what do you do if you find an amazing
fact that perfectly fits a narrative but
just can't find its primary source
how do you deal with the reality that
many scientific results have huge error
bars or maybes attached to them
how do you handle complex systems that
defy easy answers
in the end we make 10 minute videos so
we need to make decisions about what
details and explanations can fit which
aspects need to be simplified and which
parts to cut there is no single best
answer for how to do this and so we
weigh the different options every single
time
it can be painful for experts to see
their field simplified some are happy
with us while others don't like it
this is fair but also impossible to
avoid
we're still trying to improve and want
to be transparent about what we're
trying to do
for example we're taking part in the
traska project about science
communication to learn more
all of this brings us to the purpose of
our videos
the most important thing we want to do
with this channel is to inspire you and
spark your curiosity for science and the
amazing universe we live in
learning often doesn't feel like fun but
with the right story it is one of the
best things and we hope to provide that
to you
ultimately we hope that we light a fire
in you that motivates you to read books
pay more attention at school or
university and just get interested in a
scientific field or two and learn more
on your own not because you have to but
because you want to know more about how
the world really works
because the universe is beautiful and
science is a way of seeing this beauty
more clearly
and we hope that knowing that we have to
simplify a bit does not make you enjoy
our videos less
we are trying to build something with
kotzkuzak and while we're not 100 sure
yet what exactly hopefully something
that gets people to think about their
own life and the context they exist in
today as well as the far future and the
potential we all have as a species
and of course how big things are and
what happens when we blow stuff up
because it's fun thanks for watching and
sharing and supporting us we really
can't do this without you
running a science communication business
is a balancing act that we take
extremely seriously
on the one hand we need to be
responsible and look out for the team
and be able to grow responsibly on the
other hand we have to protect the
integrity of our videos
you are enabling us to stay independent
because while we do things like
sponsorships or commercial work the
majority of our income comes directly
from you the burbs
cosguard is fundamentally funded by its
community by you
because of you kotskazak is able to
invest as much time in our videos and
try to become better
you get our calendar every year support
us on patreon and get your personal
birds watch our videos without adblock
or with youtube premium our favorite way
to keep the channel running are our
sciencey products from our shop that
hopefully add additional value to the
world
we love bringing little pieces of
knowledge into your home or classroom
that inspire you to learn more about the
universe in a little more detail
especially with our carefully researched
infographic posters
our latest one teaches you about the
night sky and showcases the stars in our
night sky and their special significance
for humanity
with every purchase you directly support
what we do on this channel please don't
forget to do so though
watching and sharing is already helping
us out a lot and we are just grateful
that so many of you care about what we
try to do here
thank you so so much
[Music]